foreign
[Music]
about audit logs what they are why they
are important and how to view and find
audit logs in your Google Cloud project
in addition you will also learn about
pricing and retention of different types
of audit logs audit logs are log streams
provided as part of Google Cloud logging
to help you with your audit and
compliance needs these logs help you
find answers to questions of who did
what where and when within your Google
Cloud platform project
audit logs are broadly categorized as
admin activity data access system event
and policy denied audit logs to learn
more about audit log types watch this
video titled understanding audit logs
now let's look at identity and access
management roles and permissions around
audit logs we can use this to minimize
who has access to audit logs which can
be quite sensitive to prevent unwanted
access to other resources while deciding
which logging specific permission
enrolls are suitable for your use case
keep in mind the following the log
sphere role gives you read-only access
to admin activity policy denied and
system event audit logs while private
logs viewer role will have all the
permissions that a log sphere role has
plus the ability to read data access
audit logs for more information on IIM
permissions and roles that apply for
audit logs check out this documentation
in the link below let's dive into Google
Cloud console and learn how to view the
audit logs in your project go to logs
Explorer page in the query Builder pane
set resource to the resource type for
which you want to view audit logs for we
will set it as GCE instance
set log name to the audit log type that
you want to view in our example we will
set it as data access once you click the
apply button logs related to your
filters will start showing there you go
you can see the data access audit logs
for GCE VM instances
if I expand One log entry to go to Proto
payload dot authentication info then it
will tell us who called this method
similarly the timestamp field will tell
us when this operation was performed we
can also view audit logs by writing
logging queries in logs Explorer which
we'll see with the help of an example
let's imagine a scenario in which these
audit logs would be useful enforcing SSL
can be part of a greater networking
security strategy so it's important to
know if and when a SSL policy is
modified and who is doing it let's look
at sample log query that finds who and
when the SSL policy for load balances
were modified in our project
for audit logs the log ID will always
start with
cloudaudit.googleapis.com followed by
the audit log type of the operation
since we want to track the modification
of SSL policy set the log ID to
cloudaudit.googleapis.com activity to
search an admin activity audit logs next
set the resource type as GCE Target
https proxy to tag the actions for SSL
policy finally the Proto payload dot
method name Will point to the API call
which is B1 dot compute.target https
proxies dot set SSL policy for this
example
when this query is executed in Google
Cloud console make sure to select the
time frame for which you want to view
the logs yay you can now see the
activity logs for SSL policy
modification to view More Sample login
queries refer to this document now let's
look at the pricing information for
audit logs firstly ingested admin
activity and system event audit logs are
not charged for all users as they are
part of the free injection for the
required bucket and cannot be disabled
data access and policy denied audit logs
are charged based on the volume of logs
data that exceeds the free monthly
ingestion allotment
wondering how long these logs will be
available for admin activity and system
event audit logs are retained for 400
Days and cannot be configured the
default retention period for data access
and policy denied order logs are 30 days
these can be configured to retain
anywhere between one day to 3650 days
for configurable work buckets
check out the following links for more
details on audit logs access control and
pricing thank you for watching
foreign
[Music]